for all the pomp and circumstance the
famous Kentucky Derby horse race is only
a mile and a quarter long and lasts
about two minutes southerners took a
two-minute horse race and turn it into
two days of costumes and drinking
spectators dawn exceptionally large hats
and sip mint juleps a lot of them the
first Kentucky Derby was run in 1875
with only ten thousand guests compared
to today's crowds that top 150,000 the
Derby is big money setting a record for
wagering in 2012 at 187 million dollars
that's more than that your Super Bowl
beds the most a jockey can weigh is 126
pounds with equipment despite the small
stature required the Derby is still a
boys club only three fillies and six
female jockeys have raced at churchill
downs but the real question is whether
anyone will break Secretariat's 1973
record